- There's been a lot of buzz
about how the diabetes drug metformin,
could help people live longer.
Results are mixed on
metformin's actual efficacy
as an anti aging treatment.
One way metformin is supposed
to help with anti aging
is by activating a cellular
process called autophagy.
It literally means self eating.
Your cells do this all the time
to keep themselves and you healthy.
Let's go over how autophagy
works and its role in aging.
Think of autophagy as your
cells recycling system.
Cells use autophagy to get rid of proteins
and other cellular components
that aren't working properly
or could cause problems.
This process goes a little
something like this.
Little sacks engulf proteins
in structures like mitochondria,
the powerhouses of cells.
These sacks infuse with
another cellular compartment
called the lysosome.
Think of it as a cell shredder.
The sack's cargo gets broken down there
by enzymes in the lysosome.
And cells can then reuse these
materials to build new stuff.
That makes autophagy protective
against aging and stress in two ways.
It provides cells with energy,
especially when food is low
and it prevents junk from piling up.
But as we age, autophagy levels go down
and the damage our bodies accumulate
at the cellular level goes up.
Longevity experts think the damage buildup
is one of the main reasons we age.
Damage can happen even
from basic functions
like breathing and metabolizing food,
kind of like when we
burn fuel in our cars.
These reactions can
produce tiny pollutants
that can cause inflamation
and harm proteins in mitochondria.
Over time there's too much
damage or not enough repair
and cells just don't work as
well as when they were younger,
in worst case scenario, they die.
That's why certain diseases
become more common with age.
For diabetes impaired
autophagy is associated
with insulin resistance,
a hallmark of a disease,
and in some types of dementia,
brain cells that can't
get rid of protein clumps
through autophagy, they die.
By promoting autophagy,
the goal is to increase health span
or the amount of time we
can live a healthy life
free of debilitating
age related conditions
like dementia and diabetes.
And if lifespan is extended
too, all the better.
Since metformin helps increase autophagy
that might mean it also
helps prevent cellular damage
and therefore aging.
There are other drugs and
methods that can boost autophagy.
Resveratrol is an anti-tumor drug
that's also a powerful antioxidant.
And rapamycin is an immunosuppressant
that's been shown to
extend lifespan in animals,
kind of like metformin.
Some longevity experts are also looking at
intermittent fasting.
There's already preliminary evidence
that it promotes brain health.
When you don't eat, autophagy increases
to fill the energy void.
In mice, research suggests
that increased autophagy
allows them to live longer
and their organs to age less quickly
but that doesn't always
translate to humans.
Sometimes, doses that are
used in animal studies
are way higher than what
people can take safely.
Plus taking any medication
has side effects.
For metformin, those include a higher risk
of Parkinson's disease and
difficulty building muscle mass,
potentially because of too much autophagy.
And in transplant patients,
who take rapamycin more frequently
and at higher doses than
longevity bio-hackers,
common side effects can
include mouth ulcers,
loss of kidney function
and high blood pressure and
high cholesterol levels.
Understanding how people age
and why some people age better than others
could help us develop
better anti-aging therapies,
and that's critical,
given the world's
population is aging fast.
(upbeat music)